comment allez-vous non c'est bon il y
aura par une vidéo d'horreur qu'on vient
de faire le serait d'avoir cinq
histoires la vidéo d'halloween laon
calme un peu l'ambiance horrifique j'ai
trouvé une nouvelle histoire une vie
l'histoire j'ai envie de vous raconter
parce qu'elle est touchante cool
surprenante agréable je continue tous
les adjectifs pour la met en avant
aujourd'hui je vous racontais l'histoire
de steven russell qui était un fraudeur
américains dans les années 90 qui est
encore en vie aujourd'hui en seulement
cinq ans il s'est évadé quatre mois de
prison avec aucune violence juste des
petits subterfuge très malin auquel
clairement vous et moi on n'aurait
jamais pensé son histoire elle défonce
parce que il a un culot incroyable et
surtout il est touchant parce que s'ils
s'échapper de prison c'était par amour
pour le moment c'est peut-être un peu
floue pour vous de s'échapper de prison
par amour mais vous allez voir c'est ce
qui s'est passé à plat la petite pause
personnes s'y attendait même moi je m'y
attendais pas mais j'ai oublié de parler
du nouveau drop yoko dans l'intro donc
je le fais maintenant en voix off on a
sorti un nouveau drop qui s'appelle
patching go avec plein de nouvelles
pièces y compris loup dit que je porte
le nom de cette vidéo est aussi l'audi
golden boy ce pantalon lac je trouve
très cool les chaussettes yoko j'adore
je reçois beaucoup de compliments sur
les chaussettes ça me fait très plaisir
je suis ravi que vos pieds soit à l'abri
dans de belles choses
bref voilà je voulais vous soyez au
courant passe et voir ça et maintenant
passons à l'histoire comme d'habitude
contextualisations commence par son
enfance qui est pas ouf spoiler steven
né en 1957 en caroline du nord aux états
unis mais avant même sa naissance c'est
déjà la merde juste avant sa naissance
ses parents divorcent et sa mère ne veut
pas avoir à élever cet enfant en dehors
du mariage donc elle a une solution pour
ça c'est tout simplement l'abandonner
sur le parking d'un hôpital mon frère
m'a déjà fait la blague quand j'étais
plus jeune toit de façon on a trouvé
abandonné dans la rue ça m'a blessé pas
très drôle florence est d'ailleurs
sache-le lui c'est la réalité rassurez
vous pas ce qu'il va être recueillie par
une famille très rapidement après son
abandon qui va l'élever comme leur fils
et qui va lui dire l'année de ses 9 ans
qu'il a été adopté évidemment ils
adorent ils aiment profondément ses
parents adoptifs mais quand même il
comprend pas pourquoi il a été abandonné
et du coup pour compenser commence à
faire des conneries genre beaucoup de
conneries par exemple à l'école ils
adorent la bagarre la castagne mais
rassurez-vous à côté de ça il fait pas
que de se bagarrer il est pris de
passion pour un truc [ __ ] le feu à des
choses c'est pas la meilleure des
occupations c'est pas celle qui débouche
sur un an dire incroyable ses parents
décident donc de le mettre dans un foyer
pour garçons histoire de reprendre en
main son éducation et calmer le jeu et
devinez quoi ça marche plutôt bien
rapidement et l'arrêt de [ __ ] le feu à
quoi que ce soit il arrête ses bêtises
bref il se reprend en main et il
continue d études dans lesquelles il
n'est pas spécialement brillant quelques
années plus tard le foyer c'est fini
pour steven et il entame une nouvelle
vie dans un premier temps il va bosser
dans l'entreprise familiale dans
l'agroalimentaire et il se prend aussi
un peu de passion non pas pour [ __ ] le
feu à des trucs rassurez vous mais pour
la police et il devient sur son temps
libre officier volontaire de police ce
qui est assez ouf quand vous allez voir
on apprend la suite de l'histoire et on
apprend qu'il va devenir l'un des hommes
les plus recherchés du pays mais
actuellement ça se passe tellement bien
avec la police qui se met à fricoter
avec la secrétaire du chef de la police
débit et attendez il se marie avec il se
marie avec et deux ans plus tard il a
une petite fille steffy bref vous
l'aurez compris c'est vraiment repris en
main il a un travail il a une femme il a
une fille franchement il est droit et il
a l'avenir devant lui comme on dit mais
malgré tout il a une obsession il veut
retrouver ses parents biologiques et
c'est à cause de cette obsession que
steven va anormalement passé beaucoup de
temps dans les fichiers de la police
fichiers dans lesquels tu peux obtenir
globalement n'importe quelle information
sur n'importe qui et cette infraction va
payer parce qu'à force de try hard il va
retrouver la trace de ses parents
biologiques
ça fait neuf ans qu'il a ça en tête et
enfin il a trouvé leur nom il a trouvé
leur adresse et il s'apprête à apprendre
un truc qui va le mettre au sol quelques
temps après qu'il soit abandonné sa
maman c'est en fait remarier avec son
père et ils ont ensemble eu deux enfants
qu'ils ont cette fois garder et qu'ils
élèvent dans la maison familiale voilà
en gros c'est une famille normale juste
heaven il a dégagé quoi malgré tout ils
se remettent ce coup dur n'oubliez pas
qu'il a une femme des enfants un travail
et continue sa vie et en 1985 nouveau
coup dur son père adoptif décède et sa
salle affecte salle affecte énormément à
tel point qui remet un peu toute sa vie
en question et il se rend compte qu'en
fait ils pensent que ça fait pas mal
d'années qu'il a refoulé son
homosexualité à cause de ses parents
très conservateur et religieux c'est
souvent quand on vit un truc très dur
quand on se rend compte de certaines
choses et qu'on décide de changer de vie
et prendre un nouveau départ et voilà
c'est ce que steven va faire il explique
à sa femme qu'il est en réalité
homosexuelle et il divorce à l'amiable
puis décide d'aller à los angeles pour
repartir à zéro il trouve un job sympa
et cache plus du tout son orientation
sexuelle c'est bon il s'assume il est
lui même sauf que on est dans les années
90 et ya énormément de mots phobies et
son boss en comprenant que steven est
homosexuel va tout simplement le dégager
du jour au lendemain là clairement il
est démotivé il se dit bon ben vas-y
flemme de trouver un travail si c'est
pour faire humide et à cause de mon
orientation sexuelle je vais trouver un
autre moyen de gagner de l'argent et le
premier autres moyens qu'ils trouvent
pour gagner de l'argent c'est une petite
fraude à l'assurance il veut simulé un
accident pour toucher les 40 mille
dollars de son assurance vous connaissez
la suite c'est la piéride air
l'assurance mène l'enquêté elle se rend
compte que steven a complètement menti
il appelle donc la police pour les
prévenir la police fait une petite
enquête histoire de elle découvre des
trucs encore plus compromettants steven
est un petit cachottier nous l'a pas dit
ni à vous ni à moi mais en fait il avait
une fausse carte d'identité ainsi qu'un
faux passeports ainsi que des fausses
rolex qu'il vendait très cher pour cette
fois steven est relâché sous caution
c'est à dire qu aux etats unis le
système fait que quand tu es jugé tu
peux payer une caution qui t'offre du
temps de liberté avant de débuter à
peine de prison et c'est pendant cette
petite période de liberté que steven
fait une rencontre game center il fait
la rencontre de james kempen et les deux
tombe fou amoureux
à tel point qu'ils vont se mettre en
couple et emménager ensemble très
rapidement à palm beach en floride bref
ils vivent leur meilleure vie et c'est
la première fois que stephen vis un truc
pareil avec un homme et oui n'oubliez
pas que ces agressions pour lui son
coming out la justice arrivants y
puisque le jugement de stephen a lieu et
il est condamné pour fraude à six mois
d'emprisonnement ferme on est en 1992 et
c'est fini 2 qui fait avec son amoureux
steven tu vas dans la prison daris
county à houston est ton amoureux tu
l'auras au téléphone malheureusement son
amoureux james est atteint du sida et il
est dans une phase avancée du sida et
autant vous dire que dans les années 90
le sida c'est vraiment mal soignée donc
james n'a plus beaucoup de temps devant
lui et c'est pour ça que steven pète un
câble parce que il sait que son amoureux
n'a plus beaucoup de temps à vivre et
malgré tout il va perdre six mois six
mois pendant lesquels il serait en
prison et pour lui ça c'est inconcevable
il va donc mettre toute son énergie dans
l'élaboration d'un plan pour ceux cassés
de tôle il prend un job au sein de la
prison ce qui fait qu'ils sortent plus
régulièrement de sa cellule que s'il en
avait pas et ça lui permet d'analyser
beaucoup plus rapidement l'environnement
dans lequel ils se trouvent il repère
une pièce dans laquelle les nouveaux
détenus arrivent et laissent leurs
vêtements de civils avant de rejoindre
leur cellule pour stephen c'est réglé
ils volent en jean il vole un tee shirt
et il est cash dans sa cellule il a
repéré que l'infirmière à un talkie
walkie pourparlers avec les gardes il va
se faire passer pour un malade et lors
de son passage à l'infirmerie stewball
qui il va le volet on est le 22 mai 1993
et steven décide que c'est le jour où il
va retrouver son amoureux il enfile les
vêtements il prend le talkie walkie et
il attend que les gardiens aillent se
faire une petite pause clope il reste
une seule gardienne qui fait pas trop
gaffe à ce qui se passe autour d'elle
c'est maintenant ou jamais steven marche
d'un air confiant vers la porte qui
permet de sortir du bloc et ça marche la
gardienne fait pas trop gaffe en levant
la tête elle voit quelqu'un dit civile
avec un talkie et à lui ouvre la porte
il marche fièrement vers la sortie il
tape contre l'avis de l'accueil en
montrant son talkie walkie et devinez
quoi la personne nuit où on lui demande
pas s'identifier on lui pose pas de
questions bref c'est tellement gros ce
qu'il en train de tenter que ça passe
genre personne ne tenterai ça s'il était
en train de s'évader steven vient donc
de s'enfuir d'une des plus grosses
prison du texas en marchant tout droit
vers la sortie bon c'est cool il s'est
échappé sauf que maintenant il est en
cavale et il va tôt ou tard se faire
griller parce que sa cellule est vide
alors qu'est ce qu'il va faire selon
vous est ce qui va faire une mcafee et
fuir au guatemala et ce qui va changer
d'identité et de vie à tout jamais est
ce qu'il va faire un move de génie comme
à chaque fois
steven il va juste chez james il lui dit
je t'aime mon amour je suis ravi de te
retrouver et c'est tout il n'y a pas de
plan sans pression et prépare la petite
valise trois caleçons des tee-shirts ils
vont à l'aéroport est content ce bar une
semaine au mexique en vacances arrivée
au mexique quand même steven se dit
attends tu attends je peux pas m'en
sortir ils vont me retomber dessus il
faut que j'aie un plan il faut que je
fasse un truc de malade et il a une idée
il appelle la prison ils parlent ou
garder leur dit allez gas et steven le
mec qui s'échappe et sachez que lâchés
en république dominicaine je me la coule
douce au soleil et je voulais juste vous
présenter mes excuses pour m échapper
pendant votre pause clope et franchement
il est fier is dix mecs j'ai tellement
brouiller les pistes j'aurais fait
croire que j'étais en république
dominicaine je suis tellement un génie
devinez combien de temps il arrive à
rester au mexique sans se faire
retrouver après ça deux ans c'est énorme
malheureusement l'état james se dégrade
fortement à cause du sida et ils sont
dans l'obligation de rentrer aux états
unis pour qu'on lui prodigue des soins
urgents et forcément y'a pas de sécurité
sociale aux états unis les soins coûtent
cher très cher donc steven il doit
trouver des moyens de faire de l'argent
pour payer le traitement à son copain
évidemment il se fait de l'argent
faisant des trucs illégaux en fraudant
comme il l'a fait avec l'assurance une
première fois ce qu'il remet vite sur le
radar de la police les policiers le
retrouvent et le mettre en prison cette
fois n'y a pas d'histoire de liberté
sous caution il s'est échappé il faut
pas refaire l'erreur est malheureusement
pendant qu'il est en prison james
décèdent de sa maladie tout pourrait
s'arrêter là on pourrait se dire que
c'est bon il a fini sa folie amoureuse
qu'il a plus grand chose à faire à part
purgé sa peine puis retourner à sa vie
normale mais non en 1995 alors qu'il
passe tout son temps à la bibliothèque
de la prison steven va tomber amoureux
d'un autre homme cet homme c'est philip
morris rien à voir avec les clopes
philip morris est un homme intéressé par
la loi c'est donc tout naturellement que
steven pour le séduire va lui mentir
droit dans les yeux en faisant genre qui
les juristes juste pour l'impressionner
comme ça on commence le couple sur de
bonnes bases du beau mensonge les deux
hommes tombent amoureux et steven se
débrouille mais pour être enfermés dans
la même cellule que philip morris son
voyage en prison se transforme donc en
une colocation entre amoureux cette
colocation elle dure un an un an après
lesquels les deux hommes en octobre 96
sont libérés sous contrôle judiciaire ah
sacré steven fait des petits boulots à
droite à gauche et qui fout ta vie une
vie normale loin de la prison c'est pas
les plans de steven steven silver
impressionné philip morris je parle pas
des clopes et pour ça il veut devenir un
grand nom dans la finance il n'a pas de
diplôme en rapport il commence par
écrire une annonce de recrutement dans
un journal local vous avez bien entendu
une annonce de recrutement dans la non
s'il se présente comme une importante
multinationale à la recherche de cadres
expérimentés parce que comme ça il ya
des tas de gens qui sont très qualifiés
dans le monde de la finance qui lui
envoient leur cv et lui ce qui va faire
ce qu'il va prendre tous les cv et va
faire un bon remix pour faire son propre
cv crédible de mecs qui pèse dans la
finance peu de temps après et tombe sur
une offre d'emploi pour devenir
directeur financier de l'une des plus
grandes boîtes de médicaments des états
unis la north american medical
management et il se dit ce job est fait
pour moi dans son cv tous les numéros
qui l'a associé aux compagnies dans
lesquelles il prétend avoir travaillé
c'est des numéros qui sont reliés à sa
ligne donc quand il reçoit un message
d'un recruteur il le rappelle en se
faisant passer pour un mec qui bosse
dans l'entreprise en question et il lui
dit à steven ce mec-là beau c'est
tellement bien
c'est absurde et devinez quoi tout le
monde l'a d'or ses collègues sont hyper
satisfait son boss est trop content il
est fier de son travail l'entreprise va
même aller jusqu'à dire que c'est l'un
des meilleurs directeurs financiers qui
n'ait jamais eu tellement il est
efficace steven se retrouve donc avec un
énorme salaire et il commence a claqué
beaucoup d'argent dans le luxe pour
impressionner son amoureux philippe il
s'achète une villa avec piscine des
mercedes ils vont dans des restaurants
de malades tous les soirs bref stevens
devenue un golden boy dans le plus grand
des cales alors que c'est juste le plus
grand des mythomanes il est directeur
financier de l'entreprise c'est-à-dire
qu'il a accès à tous les comptes en
banque de l'entreprise et donc quand il
découvre que l'un des comptes en banque
contient 150 millions de dollars et fait
une petite dinguerie il prend les 150
millions de dollars et les investis en
bourse comme ça sans prévenir personne
et encore une fois ce qui est incroyable
c'est que ça marche bien son move ne
ruine pas du tout l'entreprise au
contraire ça va générer 1,6 million $ en
seulement cinq mois et lui va
discrètement se virer la moitié des 1,6
million sur son compte alors pourquoi
est il pris un tel risque lui en tant
que directeur financier parce qu'il n'a
pas le droit de faire ça et pourquoi il
fait un move dans lequel et risque de
faire perdre 150 millions $ à son
entreprise ces étrangers il ya une
raison particulière à ça et elle est
compréhensible souvenez-vous son premier
amoureux james est mort du sida et il en
est mort plutôt rapidement par manque de
soins pourquoi parce que les soins
coûtent très cher et ça stevens à lui a
foutu la n a jamais envers les entités
médical des états unis il trouve que le
prix des médicaments et des traitements
est anormalement élevé en plus de ça il
a entendu pas mal de faux au bureau des
collègues à lui dire des dingueries sur
les gens atteints de maladies c'est donc
ce qui l'a poussé un jour a pété un
câble un matin en se levant et apprendre
les 150 millions de dollars de
l'entreprise allait foot en bourse en se
disant bon si ça fait de l'argent je
suis bien si je perds tout ce sera ma
vengeance contre ces entités médical
bref l'entreprise gris que l'argent a
été déplacée cette fois stephen il
risque gros c'est pas genre de la fraude
c'est du détournement de fonds mais
cette fois stephen il a mis aussi son
amoureux dans la merde le filet parce
qu'il a ouvert des comptes en banque à
son nom dans son dos sur lesquelles il
mettait de l'argent qu'ils avaient
gagnés grâce à ses multiples fraudes
cette fois la police sait très bien
qu'elle a à faire donc il le libère sous
caution mais cette fois la caution c'est
pas quarante mille dollars comme à
chaque fois ces neuf cent mille dollars
les autorités savent qu'il n'a pas les
moyens de payer une caution aussi élevé
et donc qu'il n'a pas les moyens de
créer une nouvelle opportunité pour
échapper à sa peine de prison vous le
connaissez maintenant stephen à un plan
il me donne chaud il a tellement de
plans la température monte steven
appelle un ami à lui et lui demande de
lui faire une lettre de caution
falsifiés qui stipule une caution de 45
mille dollars au lieu des 900 milles
annonce est arrivé au tribunal master
class il ya une employée qui passe à
côté bus avec des gros dossiers dans les
mains un employé du tribunal et steven
fait volontairement tomber par terre la
lettre falsifiés de la caution vu que le
papier à l'air officiel il ya des
tampons etc c'est un truc vraiment bien
falsifiés il ya des agents du tribunal
qui ramassent la lettre et capel
l'employé pour lui dire qu'elle a fait
tomber un papier qui provient sûrement
de l'énorme dossier qu'elle a entre les
bras maintenant de cette fausse lettre
de caution se balade dans les dossiers
steven décide d'appeler le tribunal et
il se fait passer pour le juge il dit à
l'employé au bout du fil qu'une lettre
de caution se trouve dans le dossier
mais qu'elle n'a pas encore été intégrés
aux fichiers informatiques l'employé
pense effectivement qui est une erreur
elle retrouve la lettre falsifiés de
steven sauf qu'elle croit que c'est une
vraie et du coup elle change la caution
pour la rabaisser à 45 milles dollars
comme indiqué sur ce papier steven peut
maintenant payer la caution il sort du
tribunal et il est de nouveau en liberté
quand est-ce que tu arrêtes steve qu'en
quelques jours après les autorités se
rendre compte une fois de plus de la
supercherie là ça rigole plus steven et
prend 45 ans de prison ferme on est en
96 l'année de ma naissance on s'en fout
sauf que cette fois stephen n'est pas
incarcéré dans la prison habituel il le
change exprès de prison pour le mettre
dans une prison de laquelle personne ne
s'est jamais échappé les stèles unit à
huntsville au texas il reprend ses
bonnes vieilles habitudes et et
l'analyse et y remarque que les médecins
qui se rendent à la prison pour soigner
des détenus ils ont une blouse verte et
cette blouse verte elle ressemble
drôlement à la tenue des prisonniers
sauf qu'elle est verte alors stephen il
commence à prendre des cours d'art dans
la prison dans l'unique but de voler
tous les feutres vert qu'il croise hiver
sous l'angle des feutres dans son évier
il y plonge sa tenue et devinez quoi
malheureusement verte c'est tout la
chute est pas atteint il a maintenant
une tenue verte qui ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau à celle de médecins et
donc docteur steven décide de sortir de
sa cellule et de se casser il est
nouveau en liberté il vient d'échapper à
45 ans de prison où va steven selon vous
il rejoint son amoureux mais cette fois
ils sont pas débiles il change
immédiatement détaillées se rendre dans
le mississippi pour essayer d'échapper
aux recherches policières et je vais
vous dire je suis fier de ce qu'ils
apprennent de leurs erreurs c'est beau
je suis je suis un peu ému à la fin de
la blague les policiers avaient mis
philippe sur écoute philippe à appeler
ça un moment pour lui donner des news
les policiers ont réussi à tracer
l'appel à les dix jours après son
évasion il est donc retrouver retour en
prison steven passe plusieurs mois en
prison et il ne s'échappe pas les gardes
sont presque inquiet se disant [ __ ]
c'est pas échappé il doit aller mal et
effectivement il va mal il est hyper
affaibli il mange quasiment plus rien il
est squelettique les bulletins santé
montrent que steven a en fait le sida un
stade très avancé qu'il a plus beaucoup
de temps à vivre et dans ce cas là la
justice autorise les prisonniers à
rejoindre des prisons un peu plus light
pour qu'ils profitent entre guillemets
un peu plus de leurs derniers jours
avant de mourir il est donc transférée
et quelques temps après son transfert
cette prison auspices reçoit un appel
cet appel c'est celui d'un médecin un
médecin qui leur explique que steven est
éligible à un traitement expérimental
censé soigner le sida il est donc envoyé
en ville pour faire ce traitement et
quelques semaines plus tard
malheureusement la prison auspices
reçoit de nouveau en appel du médecin
qui cette fois leur dit que le
traitement expérimental n'a pas suffit
et que steven a succombé à sa maladie
c'est une triste fin pour stevens et
brutal c'est on aurait aimé presque
l'histoire continue et elle continue
qu'est-ce que tout est faux il s'est
échappé une fois plus en fait pendant
dix mois il a pris la blinde de laxatifs
steven schier toutes sortes qui fait
qu'il a perdu et or mais moins de poids
et qu'il avait l'air super faible quand
ils allaient à la bibliothèque il
écrivait des faux bulletins de santé et
il a réussi à les faire rentrer dans le
système interne de la prison le médecin
qui a appelé la prison de foix c'est pas
un médecin c'était steven et en plus de
tout ça steven il a quand même réussi à
faire remplir un vrai certificat de
décès en se faisant passer encore une
fois pour un médecin donc là aux yeux
des autorités et du monde stephen est
mort ce qui intéresse steven est ce qui
nous intéresse aussi c'est que quand il
s'échappe il retrouve son amoureux sinon
ça sert à rien globalement mais cette
fois il ya un problème le p il est en
prison c'est donc tout naturellement que
steven se met à usurper l'identité d'un
avocat pour rendre visite à philippe en
prison je pense que dans l'histoire
l'humanité ya pas beaucoup de gens qui
sont échappés de prison et qui sont
retournés volontairement bon alors il
lui rend visite il est content il le
voit il peut lui parler mais il n'est
pas vraiment avocat donc il va pas
réussir à diminuer sa peine de prison il
faut donc qu'ils se payent un avocat
méga compétent pour espérer diminuer la
peine de filet il prend donc rendez vous
dans une banque pour essayer d'obtenir
un trait de 75000 dollars et donne un
faux nom sauf que le banquier et mega
suspicieux puisque le nom que steven lui
donne ne correspond à aucun dossier de
la banque dans le doute pendant le
rendez-vous le banquier prévient
discrètement la police et un agent est
envoyé sur place pour éclaircir la
situation et qui arrivent sur place un
inspecteur qui a suivi le cas de steven
pendant des années l'inspecteur
reconnaît immédiatement steven et se dit
il n'est pas mort le frérot est le plus
ouvre ces cas seulement quelques jours
près steven il se serait jamais fait
retrouver parce qu'il avait un rendez
vous prévu dans une clinique de
chirurgie pour tout simplement changé de
visage celle-ci ce jour là il n'avait
pas croisé par hasard au coin d'une rue
probablement il aurait jamais retrouvé
cette fois les autorités en ont marre de
passer pour des turbos nullos et ils se
disent l'asie sanctions exemplaires en
août 2000 steven est condamné à cent
quarante quatre ans de prison ferme en
plus de ça il change ses conditions de
détention et il se retrouve en isolement
la majeure partie de son temps autant
vous dire que pousser un chariot rempli
de boue fougue linge pour observer et
préparer un plan c'est fini c'est plus
possible ça fait donc un peu plus de 21
ans que steven est en prison dans ces
conditions aujourd'hui il a quasiment
aucun contact humain il est âgé il est
en fauteuil roulant et ils n'arrêtent
pas de demander aux autorités de le
mettre dans une cellule normale et que
de façon ils ont pu s'échapper c'est bon
il a fait 20 ans il est vieux il juste
purgé sa peine tranquille
malheureusement quand schaper quatre
fois de prison battait pas trop en
mesure de demander quoi que ce soit et
les autorités en plus elles se sont fait
humilier c'était un fiasco médiatique
donc elles prennent 0 risque qu'elle le
laisse dans des conditions de détention
très dures voilà donc comment se termine
l'histoire de steven l'histoire de
semaine qui s'est échappé plat fois de
prison il a le record je crois du monde
et il s'est échappé en plus par amour ce
qui rend le truc très tout change aux
dernières nouvelles sa fille lui rend
régulièrement visite est aussi des
journalistes qui passent le voir et qui
recueille son témoignage l'histoire de
sa vie le récit de sa vie et le
décrivent comme un homme qui a un
charisme énorme une facilité de dingue
pour s'exprimer bref c'est vraiment un
mec qui a une chatte ch de fous et ils
comprennent en lui parlant comment il a
fait en fait comment tout ce qu'il
raconte est vraiment arrivé parce qu'on
peut se dire mais c'est pas possible
c'est trop gros mais non c'est vraiment
arrivé apparemment lui parlant tu te
projettes un peu plus sur le pourquoi du
comment et si vous avez qui fait cette
histoire je vous invite à regarder un
film que j'ai moi même pas vu mon nom je
fais cette vidéo mais que je vais
regarder qui s'appelle i love you
phillip morris qui est sorti en 2007
2009 chez plus et dans lequel jim carrey
incarne steven et apparemment il ya même
un petit caméo dans le film de philippe
philip morris le vrai de la vraie vie
bref j'espère que ça vous a plu j'espère
que vous étiez pas très nombreux à
connaître cette histoire personnellement
je la connaissais pas du tout malgré le
fait qu'elle soit assez incroyable et
qui est un film carrément dessus mais ça
va regarder à très vite pour d'autres
histoires étonnantes portez vous bien je
galère toujours autant à finir les
vidéos
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]